obviously the toilet in a separate room  i think that's not revolutionary but the  fireplace is a heat generating fireplace  so and it's by the bathtub so the  bathtub in the corner would be a cold  part of the house except for  there's a fireplace and  it's electric it's going to turn on okay  and then it'll uh  light up oh nice and that's really cool  and then  last but not least actually one other  thing is the chandelier so i love it  because you can do like cool lighting  you can turn this down oops that's not  not the best example but you get the  idea  so that was really cool and then because  we have music throughout the whole house  we also have music in our bathroom